now we're trying to protect our children
children of Clark County from being
assaulted whether it's physically
sexually mentally
we do thank you for
eign
Joyce We Begin this half hour with a
look at students safety in the Clark
County School District one-way schools
are working to protect the students is
by upgrading School Bus cameras so the
district spent millions of dollars on
this new system but data shows violence
on school buses is a track to eclipse
last school year 8 news now education
reporter Joshua peguero digs into the
map
CCSD has 2 000 school buses transporting
around 120 000 kids daily and sometimes
violent incidents pop up between bus
drivers and students Michael Kane and
Bradley Myers of the 702 firm Are
representing the family of Vincent Brown
a fourth grader allegedly attacked on
his way to the variety School in
November of 2022. we have a special
needs student that gets you know abused
by the the bus driver who's supposed to
be protecting and looking out for the
kids that's that uh I think anyone's
compelled by that story Doris Tovar was
arrested by CCSD police and is facing
one count of child abuse court documents
allowed she struck the nine-year-old in
the face spotting limbs torso and the
extremities when you're dealing with a
special needs student or child
especially one who is non-verbal the
long-term ramifications of an incident
like this an assault and battery his
lawyers allege Brown was subjected to
physical and psychological abuse and we
have to invest to find out if there's
any sort of systemic problem within the
school are there are these other
incidents in any way related to maybe a
lack of training a lack of supervision
eight news now obtained data for three
years of school bus incidents it shows
the number of weapons fights assaults
and harassment when down in the
2021-2022 school year compared to the
2018-2019 year yet from the start of the
current 2022 school year to mid-march
those incidents look on track to pass
the previous School Year's total Doris
tolvar is currently on unpaid leave
she's been with the district since 1998.
Joshua peguero eight news now
now in a statement on the new security
cameras the district says in part CCSD
has video cameras on all buses to
protect students camera equipment is
regularly audited to ensure that it's
working that it's properly functioning
and video is reviewed to ensure
compliance with District policies as
well as any time there is a reported
incident on a bus